who's busy making really embarrassing
Tick-Tock videos while her City Burns is
now demanding a raise
[Music]
I'm like a Chicago mayor Lori Lightfoot
proposing a city ordinance that would
give herself a five percent pay bump
because of Biden's inflation adding
about ten thousand dollars who are
already cushy over two hundred thousand
dollar salary proving once again the
Democrats always get rewarded for their
incompetence crimes up 37 percent in the
windy city since last year and a handful
of big businesses have fled Dana from a
Communications perspective is now the
time you want to be demanding a raise I
think probably not I guess the situation
is the city council itself is getting a
raise so she's like why can't I get in
on this deal and it's like a five
percent raise but there's a lot of
people out there who are like well we
can't even afford to get back and forth
on our commute and also what about the
murder rate you know I I think that some
of these cities would be pretty
interesting if you could figure out a
way to tie your sat the salary of a
public official to things that really
matter to a city like a murder rate so
if the murder rate goes down to X you
can get you know it's like an incentive
pay for doing better for the citizens I
don't see what in Chicago has gone
better that she would deserve a race and
you know she's going to cash out after
she's mayor she's going to be probably
making almost a million dollars a year
at some board or whatever she's doing
can't she just wait does she need the
extra 10 grand right now the only way
this incompetent nimkum poop can get a
raise is if she Awards herself wine this
is she's a perfect example of how
politics attracts incompetent cretans
this person could never survive in the
private sector and as long as you can
win elections through intimidation this
is her life it's all based on identity
politics she's black she's lesbian what
else do you know about her you know that
she's presiding over a murder capital
how many people were shot and killed
while she does these clever little Tick
Tock videos a lot and lastly I want to
remind everybody after this show Google
Lori Lightfoot and Yelp review limo
company you will thank me so much when
you read her review of the limo company
then you'll re you'll see her character
in a nutshell on a page an awful person
give us a hint oh it's terrible she
reviewed her limo company and accused
the driver of using her bathroom it's
one of the funniest things you'll ever
read and the company said we know when
the driver leaves the car when the
driver's in the car driver never left
the car you're crazy and they give 20
reasons why but let me tell you she is
not only tone deaf she's selfish this
woman is selfish she's talking about
dancing and singing and making more
money and saying I'll only talk to you
if you're if you're a black uh reporter
I mean shame on this woman a violent
crime has increased 37 percent motor
vehicle theft 74 wow if you've got a car
that runs chances are they're going to
steal it from you this woman deserves
nothing I don't even think she should be
paid anything forget about tying her
salary to the murder rate just Tire
salary to the fact that that people
businesses are leaving the city what was
it McDonald's
yeah Boeing there were a bunch of them
that we talked about she is an
embarrassment she should be gone they
should recall her I have a proposal
Heraldo public officials should not be
able to vote themselves pay raises while
they're on the job you can vote a pay
raise for that position but it doesn't
kick in until the following politician
takes yourself I don't know I don't have
a particular problem with with that uh
Jesse but going back to dance one I
think that that's a great idea to tie
politicians compensation with
performance uh Cold Stone uh you know
objective this many murders this this uh
so far no one would run by the but I
must say in her defense in her defense
this salary increase would put her on a
park to ROM Emmanuel who is the mayor uh
some years ago eight years so it just
gives her parity there why was Ron
making more because he they dictate what
their salaries are in his brother is
and the race is kept at five percent I
mean your Social Security cost of living
uh uh bump is even more than five
percent but isn't she embarrassed she's
doing a terrible job objectively well I
I'm not going to defend Lori Lightfoot
and Chicago the murder rate in Chicago
because everyone knows it's a national
disgrace but is it her fault are they
doing yeah where's the federal
government
where's the yes in charge of the Police
federal government stop Trump said I'll
help you and she said get out of town
all right Geraldo hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else